il y a eu l'été des spritz l'été des
Césars mais depuis quelques mois tous
les yeux sont tournés vers les cocktails
prête à boire sans alcool autant les
gens de l'industrie que les
consommateurs
[Musique]
dans les bars et à la maison on boit
outrement est-ce que vous connaissez les
prêts à boire sans alcool ça veut dire
ça le goût de Jean voilà non non
on a vraiment l'impression que du jean
dedans
c'est bizarre il manque un petit peu de
punch parce que vous trouvez qu'il
manque quelque chose
au Canada on trouve plusieurs dizaines
de marques de cocktail sans alcool avec
des prix variantes de 2 à plus de 6
dollars pour 355 ml la plupart des
produits proposent des arômes de
cocktail classique mais on trouve aussi
quelques produits innovants élaborés par
infusion ou avec des épices Jean Boréal
ou bleuet hobby de genièvre ou Negroni
ouest de pamplemousse au Québec atypique
a été le premier à offrir ce type de
produit mais Roméo Jin c'est vite
inscrit dans la course
on a la notion de la canette du prêt à
servir de la facilité et sentez bien
être tout ça ensemble avec les
recommandations de consommation d'alcool
à la baisse disons que c'est un tempête
parfaite Romeo
dans les spiritueux ou pays et un des
premiers à offrir des cocktails prêts
qu'il y avait de plus en plus de place
plus en plus de qualité au niveau du
prête à manger et quand on a lancé en
2018 un prête à boire haut de gamme le
consommateur réagi d'une façon
foudroyante donc on a décidé de refaire
un peu la même chose après avoir sans
alcool mais pour nous c'est évident
qu'il fallait qu'on offre la même
expérience
on va vendre entre 80 000 et 100000
caisses à la SAQ de prêts à voir
alcoolisé actuellement annuellement en
2022 première année on a vendu à peu
près 70 000 caisses en épicerie en sans
alcool donc pour nous on a déjà
quasiment une parité avec ou sans alcool
l'offre des prêts à boire à exploser
dans les épiceries comme elle a SAQ
c'est vraiment une demande du
consommateur on l'a vu la tendance
émerger un petit peu partout le
consommateur aussi elle a SAQ le
demander quand on sait que 82% selon une
étude de Nelson réalisée aux États-Unis
l'an dernier 82% des consommateurs de
faibles en alcool ont aussi acheté des
produits avec alcool dans la même année
quand on regarde il y a 5 ans ça triplé
depuis 5 ans puis depuis trois ans ça
plus que d'oublier donc c'est une
tendance qui est vraiment émerger
pourquoi c'est si populaire selon vous
je crois que c'est un côté commodité on
peut le traîner avec nous peu importe
l'occasion ça permet d'assortiment aussi
[Musique]
pour les acteurs de l'industrie ces
nouveaux produits sont plus qu'une mode
il y a eu un engouement aussi pendant le
covid le prête à boire venait répondre à
un besoin de consommation responsable on
sait c'est une tendance chez nos jeunes
générations c'est comme si changer son
mode de vie était nécessairement positif
pour eux et ils deviennent un peu les
ambassadeurs d'un mouvement qui est
beaucoup plus large qu'un choix de
consommation c'est quelque chose qui va
durer dans le temps je pense que les
gens veulent plus alterner Marilou
Lapointe a ouvert la première boutique
sans alcool au Québec on a fait un petit
pop-up éphémère juste pour voir tester
puis les gens se déplaçaient de Joliette
de la Rive-Nord de la rive Sud va qu'on
se dit je pense que la demande est là
l'offre des prête à boire chez apéro à
zéro et multiples et totalement
canadienne
ça commençait avec un jean puis
maintenant on est rendu avec des Roms
des aperoles c'est des tequila donc je
pense que là on a peut-être une
vingtaine trentaine de prévoir québécois
mais je pense que dans deux trois ans il
va y avoir une centaine c'est sûr que ce
qui est John tonic mais on va aussi
aller essayer de chercher des cocktails
qu'on est moins habitués peut-être qu'on
connaît un petit peu moins donc un ton
exemple un économie un Paloma qu'on est
moins habitué aussi des mioules donc
vraiment un peu de tout j'aime bien le
gin tonic je crois que je préfère au
Paloma parfois il y a des essences
naturelles parfois c'est des écorces de
fruits mais ça se change je trouve là on
sent beaucoup la vanille dans le Paloma
la plupart des produits sont élaborés à
partir d'arôme naturel la composition
générale est similaire d'un produit à
l'autre au niveau des ingrédients vous
allez voir de l'eau bien entendu vous
allez voir du sucre de canne vous allez
voir des arômes naturels et dans la
majorité des cas vous allez voir des
agents de conservation qui sont très
faible dose
il faut comprendre c'est que les agents
de conservation sont présents parce
qu'on n'a pas d'alcool l'alcool agit
comme une barrière qui empêche la
prolifération de bactéries et qui assure
une certaine stabilité notre enjeu c'est
parce qu'au niveau des arômes naturels
quand on les procure quand on les achète
les arômes naturels sont sur une base
d'éthanol donc ça contribue au
pourcentage d'alcool d'où le moins 2.5
ces traces d'alcool mais minimes ont
poussé la SAQ à adopter l'appellation
faible en alcool pour tous ces produits
le mood Jean apparaît sur certaines
canettes alors que ce sont des produits
inspirés du gin pour éviter toute
confusion la loi oblige les fabricants à
Clermont indiqué qu'il s'agit d'un
produit sans alcool on a deux formats
différents deux habillages différents on
a aussi retiré certains éléments au
niveau du graphisme pour alléger si on
veut la Vierge ce qu'il faut surveiller
aussi c'est le sucre dans ces produits
comme ce nez grenier au bel emballage le
cocktail est le plus sucré de notre
sélection
ça je trouve que à mon sens c'est celui
que je trouve qu'il se rapproche le plus
et ça peut aller jusqu'à plus de 30 g de
sucre
comme ça s'il y a 30 g de sucre on a 25
g ok
j'aurais pas dû regarder ça
[Rires]
c'est qu'il y a pas le goût artificiel
il y a pas le goût sucré c'est ça qui
est plat c'est oui c'est le tour de
sucre va être élevé mais en bouche ça va
pas être ça qu'est-ce qui est un peu
tendance je dirais c'est que les
meilleurs des fois c'est les plus sucrés
il y en a consommateur qui va vraiment
regarder son taux de sucre que ce soit
dans la version à base de spiritueux
avec ou encore faible en alcool mais
les produits à base de sucre sont demain
quand même très populaires il y a une
certaine dichotomie entre ce que les
gens disent qu'ils veulent et ce que les
gens aiment et on le voit quand on
analyse les ventes les gens quand les
sondes ils veulent acheter des breuvages
qui sont faibles en sucre mais les
marques qu'il rachètent sont celles qui
sont sucrées et plus on a de sucre plus
nos produits performants
vous m'avez une dernière question si je
bois ça est-ce que ça va être aussi bon
que un cocktail ou un cocktail qu'on
prépare devant moi c'est vraiment si
méprendre je dirais en fait que la
particularité de l'expérience du
cocktail et ça ça va toujours rester
c'est le contact quand même avec
quelqu'un qui prépare un cocktail ça ça
peut pas se changer en version prêt à
boire
[Musique]
ça c'est vraiment important on a un
nouveau client un nouveau client le
mojito